hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about biosurfactants
so let's break the term surfactants
are molecules that can lower the surface
tension between two liquids
and they have hydrophilic head and
hydrophobic tail so they are
amphipathic molecules and here
biosurfactants means that these
surfactant molecules are derived from
bacteria or funguses which are
biological sources right
and that is the implication of
biosurface so in this video we would
look at what is
what is the function of biosurfactants
what are the sources of
surfactants what are the advantage and
disadvantage of biosurfactants and what
is the use
in industry so biosurfactants have the
ability to accumulate between fluid
phase
and thereby reducing the interfacial
tension just to give you a easy example
imagine there is some oil floating on a
water in a petri dish
now if we add a little bit quantity of
biosurfactants we would
notice that oil is now dispersed
as if it works like an emulsifier
so let's try to understand this in
better way so
these biosurfactants can accumulate
between two fluid phases
and thereby forming mycelies when their
concentration increases they form
mycelies so they would trap the oil
inside these mycelies and these mycelies
have this hydrophob hydrophilic
outer surface which can easily get
dissolved into the water so these
uh oil which was not miscible now gets
totally dispersed and kind of mixed with
this fluid
and in order to understand the
consequence we have to understand it in
bit more detail so see
here there are the two layers oil and
water but
once we use the biosurfactants the lipid
molecules are now trapped inside these
mycelies and they are kind of like
dissolved into this
fluid this same principle is used
in cleaning of oil spill from oil rigs
or from boats in the ocean
so these oils which would be floating
around in
the ocean this would be super harmful
for these
aquatic animals and plants so
that is why removing these oils are
absolutely essential
and one of the way is to provide these
biosurfactants
biosurfactants would kind of emulsify
them form
small micelles and it would be easier to
pump that
oil out oil mixed with water out and
then
the the emulsion can be broken and oil
could be recovered
so this is a one of the most efficient
way
by which biosurfactants can recover oil
not only from the spillage but
also think about the
oil industry where crude oil is
extracted from the rocks and
there could be some petroleum product
which is deeply rooted in the
pores of these rock and our oil pumps
cannot really pump it out
in that case if you put biosurfactants
everything would be nicely dissolved and
it would be way easier to extract it
so for both oil extraction
and oil spill clearage biosurfactant is
very important now biosurfactant can be
derived from
different sources several fungus like
candida antarctica
achinobacter bacillus pseudomonas
originosa
are good source of biosurfactants
there are many popular biosurfactants
which are of very
industrial use such as uh ramno lipid
trihalo's lipid surfactant and
manuscript erythritol lipid
all of these are very common
biosurfactants which are used
in day-to-day industry for example
ramno lipid have a anti-microbial
property
and that's why it is used to coat the
surface and prevent
microbial biofilm formation another
biosurfactant such as fengicin
is used for its antifungal property
and it can prevent fungal infection of
crops
and that is why it can also work like a
bio pesticide other than that
cyclic lipopeptide or clp lipids
are used in oil to increase their
efficiency then
lipopeptide biosurfactants are used in
banana forms
and it would it has a strong insect
repellent activity
so obviously it is another example of
biopesticides
at least we have understood that
biosurfactants can be used
in many different aspects in
industry and also in agriculture
now cosmetic industry are now
employing biosurfactants to make
shampoos creams etc
because violent surfactant has a
emulsification
property and that is why they create
biosurface they use biosurfactant
to create these emulsifications so that
is how they are used in
uh cosmetic industry the good side
about biosurfactant is they are green
eco-friendly and they are also
sustainable
then the disadvantage part is the
initial production cost could be
high right now but with the increased
usage of
biosurfactants and increased demand the
production cost can be modulated and can
be brought
can be reduced eventually so
biosurfactants
have a lot of advantage in terms of
their usage so i hope these videos
summarize
and gives you a quick overview about
biosurfactants if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to like share and subscribe and do let
me know in the comment how you like my
video thank you guys